Well, let's build the truth table.
For the true location we have three choices,
and because this is a truth table, I write them multiple times.
We happen to know that any of those has exactly 1/3 probability,
and we'll be using this 1/3 in a minute.
Now say you guess door number 2.
With this guess Monty will show me an empty door.
He might show me door 1, 2, or 3.
Now I have all the combinations of the true location and the door I'm being shown.
Let's talk about the probabilities of each of these entries.
If the true location is 1, which has 1/3 chance,
Monty hall will not show me location 1--probability 0.
He won't show me location number 2, because that's the one I guessed.
The only location he'll show to me will be automatically location 3.
It's not the true one. It's not the one I guessed.
It's the only empty one that remains.
The probability of showing 3 given that the true location is 1 is certain,
but the true location is 1 only with a 1/3 chance.
This specific outcome that the true location is 1 and Monty Hall shows me 3
has exactly 1/3 of a chance.
Now, but analogy, you can now fill out for me the three probabilities
that correspond to the true location being 3 and Monty showing me 1, 2, or 3
into this these three things over here.